معنا من تلابيب مراسل ال الجزيره الياس
كرام الياس اذا ابدا معك فيما يتعلق بهذا
الاجتماع بين نتنياهو وعائلات الاسرى ولكن
ربما نبدا باهم ما جاء في المؤتمر الصحفي
المتحدث باسم الجيش كما تابعناه قبل
قليل بالفعل عبد القادر عاده عندما يسال
الصحفي عن ما هو الجديد ويقول لا جديد
احيانا يبدو هذا نقطه ضعف لكن واضح ب ان
هجار لم ياتي بشيء جديد هذا اليوم في
خطابه وهذا هو العنوان الرئيسي عمليا في
الخطاب على اعتبار ان هذا يدلل على ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يراوح في مكانه وربما
يغوص في وحل غزه لان الناطق العسكري لم
يقدم ما هو جديد وكرر حقيقه ما كان يكرره
في الايام الماضيه عن انجازات وما الى ذلك
ولربما العنوان الوحيد الذي اتى عليه وهو
ربما يكون جديد في هذا السياق وربما يدلل
على الم مازق الذي تعيشه القوات
الاسرائيليه في قطاع غزه عندما قال بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي زج بكتيبه جديده ايه في
منطقه خانيونس ترافقها قوه من الهندسه
وهذا يدلل على ان القوات الاسرائيليه في
المنطقه الجنوبيه اصبحت بحاجه كما يبدو
الى دعم لوجستي والى دعم هندسي والى دعم
بالعتاد والى دعم بالقوى البشريه لانها
تواجه معارك ضاريه في منطقه خان يونس وهذا
هو حقيقه العنوان الوحيد الذي يمكن
الاشاره اليه كعنوان بارز في حديث ايه
هجار هذا ال المساء على صعيد الاجتماع
الذي عقده رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
مع بعض من عائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين في
داخل قطاع غزه وهو يعني كان اختيارا من
جانب جال هرش المسؤول عن ملف الاسرى من
اجل التفادي اي صدام ما بين عائلات الاسرى
ورئيس الوزراء بنيمين نتنياهو كما حدث في
مرات سابقه لذلك تم اختيار العائلات بشكل
يعني دقيق لكي لا يحدث هنالك صدام خلال
الاجتماع وربما يكونوا ايضا مقربين سياسيا
الى بنيامين نتنياهو لكن هذا الاجتماع على
قدر كبير من الاهميه لان العائلات في
نهايه الامر تحتاج الى اجابات كثيره عن
مصير الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في
قطاع غزه لا سما بعد مقتل ثلاثه منهم
بنيران قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي يوم الجمعه
ال الفائت وهذا الامر اثار حفيظه العائلات
وغضبها وهم ارادوا من الجانب السياسي ومن
الجانب الحكومه الاسرائيليه ان يقدموا
اجوبه على هذا الموضوع ونحن نسمع اصوات في
بين عائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين في داخل
قطاع غزه التي تطالب بكل وضوح وبكل صراحه
ان على اسرائيل ان توقف هذه العمليه
العسكريه لانها تشكل خطرا على حياه الاسرى
المحتجزين وا حث الجانب الاسرائيلي حث
المستوى الس سياسي على التقدم نحو صفقه
جديده تستعيد اسرائيل بموجبها الاسرى
الاسرائيليين حتى لو كان ثمنها باهظا جدا
من ناحيه الثمن الذي ستدفعه اسرائيل مقابل
الافراج عن هؤلاء الاسرى العائلات تقول
نعم ع طيب فقط دعني اسالك عن هذا الخبر
العاجل بان المتحدث او نقل عن القناه الث
عش الاسرائيلي تقول بان عن مسؤول مطلع من
المحتمل ان تكون تكاليف الصفقه الجديده
مرتفعه لاسرائيل وكذلك تكلم عن اعاده
المخطوفين احياء هو هدف مركزي للحرب ولكن
دعني اركز على ما جاء في القناه الث عش
الاسرائيليه بالقول انه من المحتمل ان
تكون تكاليف الصفقه الجديده مرتفعه
لاسرائيل
وهم يعرفون هذا الامر منذ الصفقه الاولى
بان المرحله الثانيه سوف تكون مرحله اصعب
بالنسبه لاسرائيل تقدم من خلالها اثمان
باهظه بمعنى انها ستضطر الى الافراج عن
اعداد كبيره من الاسرى
الفلسطينيين الاسرى القدامى ومن تسميهم
بالاسرى الملطخ ايديهم بدماء الاسرائيليين
ونحن نتحدث هنا عن القيادات ال العسكريه
والسياسيه البارزه في ال في في اوساط
الفلسطينيين وهنالك اسماء وازنه في هذا
الاطار وكانت اسرائيل قد تعنت ورفضت
الافراج عنهم في الصفقات الص
والان اسرائيل تحاول ان تضع معايير جديده
في اطار الصفقه الجديده هي تريد اولا ان
تنهي ملف اطفال والنساء اولا ثم هي تريد
ان تكون ان يكون ضمن الدفعه المقبله افراج
ربما عن المسنين من بين الاسرى المرضى او
ربما المصابين وهنالك ايضا حديث عن
امكانيه ان ينضم او يكون في اطار هذه
الفئه ايضا بعض من المجندات الاسرائيليات
اللواتي ت
اسرهن في السابع من من اكتوبر لذلك هم
يعرفون بان الثمن سوف يكون باهظا لكن هم
يتحدثون عن مفاوضات مضنيه سوف تستمر لوقت
اطول هذه المره من اجل تحقيق صفقه جديده
شكرا لك الياس كرام